du coup vous allez pouvoir faire des
messages écrits d'accord donc si vous
avez si vous vous déplacez avec vos
flèches au mba accompagner les personnes
déficientes visuelles pour qu'elle
puisse être autonome face un ordinateur
c'est le défi que la start-up
versaillaise hypra a décidé de relever
corentin voiseux et jean-philippe
mengual se sont rencontrés sur les bancs
de sciences po il décide en 2015 de
lancer le premier concept de pc a accès
universel on se rend compte que
seulement deux personnes sur dix parmi
les personnes déficientes visuelles
on se rend compte que moins de 50% des
personnes âgées de plus de 60 ans
disposent d'un ordinateur à la maison et
on se dit là effectivement il ya quelque
chose qui bloque assistance vocale zoom
puissant interface simplifiée
personnalisable t'arrive de cette
solution tout compris entre 1500 et 2000
euros
voilà je pour cela qu'il faut faire
entrer la personne qui passe par l'ons
au moment où elle achète elle achète
aussi la formation donc avec le produit
ont fourni la formation pour que la
personne s'approprient l'outil dans tous
les usages qu'elle souhaite et qu'elles
puissent ensuite de manière autonome
elle le plus loin possible dans ses
usages
depuis deux ans 150 personnes en france
dont plusieurs dans les yvelines possède
la solution hypra comme cette cliente à
trappes et via un problème on décrit
culte et je vous appelle et on se trompe
on se connecte directement sur
l'ordinateur et qui m'attriste ans
objectif pour hypra dans les prochains
mois consolidée et enrichir ce concept